YAHO, YAHO, YAHO What's happening?
What's happening?
Why is my chat all gifted?
Why is my chat...
All gift and memberships?
What's happening?
Oops, our gifts.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Extra belated Oshide.
No, thank you so much.
Whoa!
Even more!
What's happening?
I love being in the year 2007.
Yeah, what are you guys doing?
What are you guys doing?
Did you finish your homework?
I'll finish my homework after I play Portal, the newest game on this new platform called Steam.
I've never heard of it before, but apparently you can get games on there.
Oh, yeah.
What's Roblox?
I've never heard of that before.
Do you mean Legos?
Those are blocks.
Right.
Fortnite.
You mean you want to come to my house?
house and build a fort tonight that sounds fun thank you guys for all the gifts thank you thank you thank you who knows if it'll catch on it probably not like a game like that just sounds too silly
Unless they add Goku.
If they put Goku...
Roblox came out in 2006.
What?
No, it didn't.
Did it?
If it did, nobody cared about it until...
Nobody cared about Roblox until, like, whatever, like, six years...
How long ago, actually?
I don't even know.
Did it get popular?
during the pandemic?
I don't remember.
I used to play it back in 09.
Then why did it get so popular recently?
2006 was the year of Roblox.
Well, nobody, well, my statement still stands.
Nobody knew who it was.
Nobody knew.
Nobody, nobody knew.
The brain rot spreading.
They spent a ton of money on it.
Oh.
Hmm.
Whatever.
Anyways, welcome, guys.
Wait, did I say welcome?
They made a bunch of code changes, which allowed for more things to be made with less limitations.
Okay, if there is, like, a game you want to play, you can find it on Roblox.
kind of insane actually have you heard of youtube i can't wait to watch the new smosh video oh yeah youtube yeah that's where my grandpa uploads he he makes videos of him just like mowing the lawn i i told him those would never blow up those those would never get popular do you guys ever watch those videos oh what's that guy's name like be mowing?
I watch those sometimes.
Wisps, I come for the future.
We are at a junction in time, no matter what.
Don't let the gorilla die.
Save who?
Oh my gosh, Brian, you didn't say the rest of the name.
Who are we supposed to save?
I watch the guy that fixes lawns and sidewalks.
Isn't that the same guy as be mowing?
He does that.
Which gorilla?
He's the catalyst.
Hmm.
R.I.P.
Can't wait to watch new YouTube poops.
Okay, but, like, YouTube poops are still coming out, which is kind of crazy.
Sometimes you'll see one, and you'll be like, well, like, sometimes I'll be like, I'll see, like, a youngin making a YouTube poop, and I'm like, whoa, whoa.
I mean, don't know.
You've created a time paradox.
Crazy to think Portal came free with the Orange Box collection.
I don't even know what that is.
The culture passed down.
YouTube poops are timeless.
Even if maybe one day we don't have YouTube anymore.
Then I still like to believe that they'll exist.
whatever whatever platform we have next blim blob blim blob poops oh hop on blim blob guys i just i'm streaming right now live on blim blob everybody everybody get on blim blob blim blob what are you talking oh tick tock no we're all on blim blob oh my gosh use the gorilla the whole time.
I was just thinking about Jimmy James earlier.
Blim Blab has too many ads.
Oh, yeah, sorry, I forgot to do my regulated Blim Blab ad.
To stream on Blim Blab, you must insert to add into your...
I wonder if this will work.
Wait, how do I add...
Create a highlight video, stream marker.
How do I in an ad did youtube take that function away from me what's shopping oh gosh product drops um there used to be a button that would allow you to just be like here's an ad and sometimes like a little pop-up would show up and be like hey you should put in an ad right now they took it away maybe because it didn't work wait you see that blim blob bloop oh my gosh yeah sure too we're all about bloops now and bloops they're only five seconds long so they're like you really have to cram all the information at once grizzly adams happy birthday happy birthday
oh blim blob don't take that i copyrighted it already what am i oh what what should my ad be oh um
you oh um i'm thinking of like a ad that i get sometimes it's so annoying sometimes so tick tock is like especially aggressive and terrible bookmark something that i might be interested in like checking out later i will forever get only ads of that item it's kind of the worst thing ever like they're like you you want this you want this you want this i'm like oh my god it's so bad it's not my birthday oh okay have a nice day
Well, I mean, well, no, because I bookmarked it.
I get women's clothing ads.
Yeah, and do they entice you?
Are you just like this white?
This might look good at me.
YouTube is only marginally less aggressive.
I think I don't get ads on desktop.
I think that's an ad blocker.
If I watch with this channel on mobile, I get...
ads.
Good morning, Minto.
I got this game, but I never played it.
If I play it while you're streaming, would it be like holding hands?
Well, you can't go further than me.
You have to remain at my pace the entire time.
I've seen YouTube now does three ads instead of two.
What?
That's like the one You can skip the ads because I just swipe on through.
So maybe there are a lot of ads, but I just ignore them.
I don't even have to, I just, you know, the unskippable ads are the absolute worst.
Those are the ones that you're just like, oh my gosh, don't you already get enough from me?
I mean, though, I ate cake today.
Well, I'm glad that your cake was not a lie.
I think the cake is real.
I think sorry I just realized um the audio disappears when I click off and I clicked off so remember to make a part two of this video once you hit the 10 minute 59 or 10 minute 59 second minute limit yes yes we have to hit the limit we have to maximize profits that's why every stream will be at part one part two part three part 4 of 10 minutes just like when they used to upload anime and the anime would be in and one episode would be in four parts what don't you happy birthday could I get a wish and tie say
uh is that really what it means or not you're can I get a confirmation The cake is real.
Turn around.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, did someone redirect?
Thank you.
Thank you for the redirect.
Thank you so much.
Sorry, I missed who it was.
I sit on the cake every day.
That's right.
Okay, I'm going to try and say it, but I'm sorry if I say it wrong.
Suk San Wan Gur Naka.
Happy birthday!
Me trying.
I try.
I maybe.
I said it right!
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Maybe I'm good.
Anyway, shall we play Portal?
I have played Portal before.
But it was many, many, many moons ago.
So, I don't remember very much.
So, this will be basically a new experience.
Oh, oh, my gosh.
It's so weird, though, everything.
Because obviously it's Valve and it's from, like, the Half-Life era.
So, everything feels...
Feels...
I hear something and I'm like, oh, half-life.
I...
Also...
Oh, my gosh.
Can I just say for a second?
Like, how good this game still looks?
I feel, oh my gosh.
Just, I wish we could kind of go back to, like, artistic direction where it doesn't rely on ultra-realism so that, you know, the games, I mean, I feel like that's why, like, Metal Gear has held up so well, too, where it just, it looks so good.
Man, it looks...
Yeah.
Just this game still looks so good.
Oh, man.
Does so much with limited resources.
Man.
You play as Jane Half-Life.
After a year of searching, I finally have a job again.
It's not in my original field, but still a good position for now.
Thanks for helping me through some tough times this year.
Oh, my God.
Congratulations.
Da-da.
What's the timer for?
Okay.
Oh, flush it.
Hello.
And, again, welcome to the Aperture Science Computer Aided Enrichment Center.
We hope your brief detention in the relaxation vault has been a question long.
Your specimen has been processed, and we are now ready to begin the test proper.
Before we start, however, keep in mind that also fun.
of all enrichment center activities serious injuries may occur for your own safety and the safety of others please refrain from
i'm back the portal will open in three two one
styling We're gonna have it the whole time, everybody.
Please proceed into the chamber lock after completing each test.
First, however, note the incandescent particle field across the exit.
This aperture science material prevents a patient grip will vaporize any unauthorized equipment that passes through it.
For instance, the aperture science weighted storage cube.
could you how could you glados how could you my tunes i can't work without my tunes
rip party cover of still live can you turn on closed captions oh yes i can thank you would it be under video audio game i'm not what's it under.
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
I missed it.
I was expecting, I was looking for like a little check mark that's like that was for like turn on subtitles.
it's right there it's right there please place the weighted storage cube on the 1500 megawatt aperture science heavy duty super colliding super button wait hold on i'm gonna turn i'm gonna change it from closed captions to there we go dialogue only sorry listen to portal radio loop 10 hours
I don't know if I should listen to that.
Whoa!
Um...
Can I open that up again for me, please?
Thank you.
Which one is it?
Oh, that one over there.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
Perfect.
Please move quickly to the chamberlock We got soft-locked immediately in the tutorial?
Okay.
I think I almost didn't make it.
Anti-softlock.
I'll find a way.
Gosh, it's so iconic, like all of this.
You're doing very well.
Please be advised that a noticeable taste of blood is not part of any test protocol.
There she is!
Unintended side effects of the Aperture Science Material Emancipation Grid, which may, in semi-rare cases, emancipate dental fillings, crowns, tooth enamel, and teeth.
What's that mean?
The portal god!
Very good.
You are now in possession of the Aperture Science handheld portal device.
With it, you can create your own portals.
These interdimensional gates have proven to be completely safe.
The device, however, has not.
Do not touch the operational end of the device.
Do not look directly at the operational end of the device.
the device do not submerge the device in liquid even partially most importantly under no circumstances should move I won't don't worry I won't do that only blue for now lame it's so trippy I gotta earn the orange tag What if the grill evaporated?
The what?
The buckles?
What if?
What if it did that?
Please proceed to the chamber, though.
Damn,
she's looking good.
Damn, look at that booty though.
Wait, is there another one up there?
To ensure the safe performance of all authorized activities, I didn't realize the orange stayed.
Well...
Oh, sorry.
Um, sorry Glados, you can keep talking.
The cake isn't a lie.
Booty shot, booty shot.
The map you just got through, I saw a streamer take five full minutes to complete.
No way.
No!
They had to be just playing.
You're doing quite well.
There's no way.
Whoa!
Can I look at myself?
Dang.
Who is that good I see?
Where did- Okay, there we are.
They had to be I know some people...
As part of a required test protocol.
We will not monitor the next test chamber.
You will be entirely on your own.
Good luck.
Oh my gosh, they trust me.
I know like, honestly, I have streamer brain pretty bad sometimes.
So I know it's definitely like...
a real thing.
But like...
There's...
Look.
It's real.
Yeah, it's fake.
Tried gore effect.
The face and body model for Chell was based off voice actor.
Wait, for Samus?
Alicia Glidewell, who played Samus in Smash Bros.
Brawl.
Cool.
Oh, watch your head!
Watch your head!
Where's it coming from?
Oh.
Little, little thick.
There we go.
Now you're thinking with portals, Minto.
Hey, oh wait, I'm stupid.
Yes, I am.
I'm always, I'm thinking.
I'm thinking.
For your own safety, do not destroy vital testing apparatus.
Sorry.
Oh, she got mad.
I thought they weren't, you said you weren't watching me.
Liar.
You said!
You weren't watching me.
Liar.
They don't trust me.
Mom doesn't trust me.
As part of a required test protocol, our previous statement suggesting that we would not monitor this chamber as an outright fabrication.
Good job.
As part of a required test protocol, we will stop enhancing the truth in three, two, one.
Ugh, my ears.
Um...
Oh.
Whoa!
Enhancing the truth.
So...
Everything that she said...
When she...
When she praised me...
When she said I was doing a good job!
When she said it was beautiful!
When she said I was the smartest person ever to exist, it was all a lie!
While safety is one of many enrichment center goals, unbelievable.
You...
Oh.
Subject name here.
Must be pride of.
Subject on how, here.
Ghost...
Land.
All true.
Did she say those things?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was literally, like, right part of the test.
Ghost Town, USA.
Woo, woo, woo, woo.
I heard her say it twice.
Thrice even.
Warning devices are required on all mobile equipment.
However, alarms and flashing hazard lights have been down to agitate the high energy pellet and have therefore been disabled for your safety.
Now use the aperture signs on stationary scaffold to reach the chamber lock.
Wait, I wasn't paying attention?
What got disabled?
Come back?
Thank you.
I'm waiting, patiently.
What if I die here?
Wait, could I...
What if I landed on this?
Would I die?
Wow, that's pretty, uh...
Pretty...
Orange down there.
Yes.
No.
Want to try it?
I should save.
You could die in the beta version.
Oh, so they took it out!
Lame.
I wish I could run.
Please know that we have added a consequence for failure.
Any contact with the chamber floor will result in an unsatisfactory mark on your official testing record, followed by death.
Good luck.
No drinking.
Okay.
Well.
There.
First try.
Easy.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Ow!
Let's see.
It's hard when I don't have more than one, you know what I mean?
Where is it?
Troll to crouch.
They're like, just duck, dummy.
Good timing for a red!
Ah!
Wait a second.
Okay, so if we do this, and then do this, wait, it's just going to be stuck in.
Ow!
Wait.
I was trying to...
I don't know what I was trying to do, actually.
Wait, this one actually is stumping me a little bit.
Oh, she's so smart.
Yeah!
I thought I could just crouch.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait, I think I get it.
I think I get it.
So that...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my gosh.
Okay, and then, uh, here.
Ah!
Wait.
No, you messed it up!
Where'd it go?
Okay, go, and then come out through here, and then bounce, and then go to there.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
And then I go, like, here.
Clutch, I know.
Oh my gosh, the timing was almost so bad.
Please come back.
My ride?
Your Uber?
Your Uber is here.
Okay.
Go for a swim.
It looks...
Scraptily deumptious.
Very impressive.
Please note that any appearance of danger is merely a device to enhance your testing experience.
Yeah, I didn't die.
I merely forgot.
got hit with the forgetty spaghetti bean.
I merely got...
The enrichment center regrets to inform you that this next test is impossible.
Make no attempt to solve it.
Impossible, huh?
Impossible, you say.
What's up here anyway?
Thank you.
The Enrichment Center apologizes for this clearly broken test chamber.
Impossible, huh?
Is there only one?
Fantastic.
You remain resolute and resourceful in an atmosphere of extreme pessimism.
I was very sad and pessimistic.
And then I triggered my inner genius.
And I felt good.
Yeah, Mint does the impossible every day.
I do!
Wait.
What do I do?
I...
What do I...
Hello again.
Hello.
I need a momentum?
I don't know how to run.
Oh, they're like...
They were like, if you put it on the ground, you'll go fast.
I...
I didn't, though.
Wee!
Oh.
Oh, up there, okay.
Alright, where can I put it on the girl here?
Oh gosh, it's always this stuff that I'm so trippy, you know?
Ah!
Spectacular.
You appear to understand how a portal affects forward momentum or to be more precise how it does not.
Dot.
Oh.
Where's the portal at?
But where?
Oh, okay, okay.
Momentum.
A function of mass and velocity is conserved between portals.
In layman's terms.
Speedy thing goes in.
Speedy thing comes out.
Easy peasy.
Yes, I understand.
Okay.
She won't miss.
We made it.
Did you see that?
Papa, are you watching me now?
She's a gamer.
She's a gamer, gamer.
Imagine doing that in VR.
Terrible.
We're not sad any longer.
No more.
More sad music.
The enrichment center promises to always provide a safe testing environment.
In dangerous testing environments, the enrichment center promises to always provide useful advice.
For instance, the floor here will kill you.
Try to avoid it.
Okay.
What just happened?
Wait.
Oh, the thing is moving.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
I was like, oh.
No.
Next one, please.
That's me.
Next, please.
Oh, there it is.
That's our out.
Yippee!
Oh, okay.
This is timed.
All right, hold on.
I'm...
I think I need to wait for it to shoot me over here.
Mathematizing, yes.
Yehoy!
Okay.
And then this guy means to...
Well, I wish I could see.
Oh, wait.
Did I get a first try?
Oh, guys!
Easiest game ever.
Oh!
Oh, that's fine, I suppose.
Oh.
Ah!
Ha!
We made it?
We made it!
The music.
This device has been modified so that it can now manufacture two-linked portals at once.
Yeah!
It's part of an optional test protocol.
How do I get out of here?
The device is now more valuable than the organs and combined incomes of everyone in.
Subject hometown, here.
Interesting.
Full power portal.
What do I, where do I, how do I get out there?
Where do I, how do I, who do I, oh, up there?
Wait!
Oh, there's a button!
Oh, I missed it.
Ah, I see, I see.
Okay, so that's blue.
So we need the orange.
Oh, gosh, I'm getting all tripped up.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come back, come back.
Everything's fine.
And we won't do the wrong one you know you know how you accent you meant to do the blue portal and you accidentally do the orange portal hot dog indeed mint rapidly aging me to dust like the end of indiana jones in the last crusade after i drink the water what did i say 30 minutes ago i really wish i could run okay we gotta go fast
Fling myself, huh?
I gotta fling myself?
We're flinging alright.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I almost made it.
Fast thing goes fast!
Oh.
Whoa.
Wait.
Where do I go from, though?
My whole...
I think.
Let's try it like this.
Oh, maybe that was overkill even.
Oh, I opened up there.
Do a flip!
Okay.
Weeeee...
The Google Translated version.
What's up?
So true, GLaDOS.
I love the turrets in this game.
I don't love the turrets, but I love how they sound.
I think they're so cute.
I love the way they talk.
They're so stinking cute.
Now that you are in control of both portals, this next test could take a very, very long time.
If you become lightheaded from thirst, feel free to pass out.
Okay.
An intubation associate will be dispatched.
to revive you with peptic salve and adrenaline.
Cool.
I want that.
Isn't it like...
I can't get over how freaky it is like watching my body go into the portal.
I know it's basically...
Oh wait.
I tried to shoot.
Certain objects may be vital to your success.
Do not destroy.
Sorry!
Okay, let's see what we got going on in here, huh?
Okay.
Do I need you?
There's two of them.
There's only one thing here, though.
Do I need both of them?
If I pick you up...
Ah, okay, no matter.
Oh wait, unless...
I shoot like a portal in here.
Yeah.
Just do that.
Okay.
That's one.
Um.
You need to go into...
There.
Now you're thinking with portals.
The music is so...
Freaky.
Okay.
And then...
So sorry, so sorry.
It was a mistake, a mistake.
My mistake, my mistakes.
Oh, my God.
How do I know?
I'm going in!
Oh, I see.
I see.
I see where it wants me to drop it.
Okay.
Wood.
Go, my cube.
Oh, try again.
Oh!
Let's go.
Go, you guys.
You know the cube car?
A long time ago, I used to...
I was like, I'm going to have my first car be the cube car, and then I'm going to make it into a companion cube Itasha.
Trick shot!
Hey, if it works, it works.
How do I get up there?
Oh, do I have to go speedy?
Speedy?
Wait, speedy?
Oh, no.
I could just do this.
Easy.
As part of a previously mentioned required test protocol, we can no longer lie to you.
When the testing is over, you will be missed.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Minto Whistle, have you ever played Pokemon Mystery Dungeon?
I actually have not played Pokemon Mystery Dungeon.
Minto.
I will be missed?
I'm gonna get vaporized?
Whoa, there's like a...
Why won't they let me drink?
All Sochic's intending to handle high-energy gamma leaking portal technology must be informed that they may be informed of applicable regulatory compliance issues no hydration no further compliance information is required or will be provided and you are an excellent test subject
wait but i guess maybe can i fly from here from here Wee!
Easy?
What's that sound?
Oh, staircase, okay.
I believe I can fly.
Mint is smart?
I don't call myself a genius for no reason.
I definitely have reason to say so.
That's no good.
That's quite bad.
That's quite terrible.
Where are you?
Guys, my bad.
Wait a second.
But now that I know...
Aiming God.
Okay.
That might have happened on purpose.
I was just speedrunning.
I was speedrunning.
Wait, which one?
I did orange.
Okay.
Very, very good.
A complimentary victory lift has been activated in the main chamber.
A victory lift?
I'm going on, I'm doing a victory lift!
Guys were almost done with the tests.
They should just tire me forever.
They should be like, we don't need any other employee ever, ever, ever.
As long as we got this girl.
She's too good.
Can you do the classic trick where you put portal?
Oh yeah, I wanted to do that before when I had...
Only the blue and then I forgot.
Yeah, we'll go in the eternal loop.
The eternal loop!
There we go.
The enrichment center is committed to the well-being of all participants.
Cake and grief counseling will be available at the conclusion of the test.
Thank you for helping us help you help us all.
It's a little messed up.
It needs a little, it needs some slight adjusting.
Wait, maybe like...
Oh, oops.
Wait.
Hold on.
Okay, here.
Oops, oops, okay.
And then...
Here.
We're reaching levels never reached before!
Ah!
Oh my god, toes!
Gamers don't look up, but they should!
That was fun.
Vital testing apparatus destroy.
Um...
How do I...
If I...
Let's see how far I get.
Not far enough.
If I run...
It was even worse.
Let's see.
Do I need to do the momentum thing and then be really good?
And like aim?
Oh my god.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Ah!
Oh, I messed it up.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
If this is orange, I need to shoot blue.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Ah, wait.
Of course that didn't work.
Okay, hold on.
This is a difficult way to do this.
Am I overthinking?
I'm overcomplicating it.
There are easier ways!
You guys know me, I overcomplicate things all the time.
Wait, how am I...
Wait, hold on, I want to reset it.
Oh wait, hold on.
I think I get... I think I know what to do.
Yeah!
I figured it out.
I figured it out!
Don't worry!
If I go through here...
Oh, it does.
Okay, interesting.
Oh, now you won't let me, huh?
Oh.
Oh!
Oops.
Oh.
Come on.
Whoa.
And then obviously you cannot...
Hmm.
This one's tricky.
I'm taking a second to explore.
In high school, I engraved Chell, the player character, onto a friend's water bottle in the energy lab.
What's that?
I always forgot how to do this one.
I'm trying to...
Because if you go through...
I think you have to...
Okay.
And you have to be fast because it eventually gets destroyed.
I kind of think I have to do what I did before.
Like this.
And then once it's in there...
Oh wait, what?
Oh wait.
Uh, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, I was too slow.
Oh, but this gets destroyed, no.
When I pass through, like, if I, yeah.
Uh, oh, you gotta be super fast.
Okay, okay.
Hold on, I'll wait for it to get destroyed.
Okay.
And then, uh, this, this one.
Wait, did I already mess it up?
Oh!
Dang it.
Wait, oh I even did the wrong one!
Okay, oh geez.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Ow!
Wait, wait, wait, go, go, go, go!
Yippee!
Okay.
Did you just Tim Allen Grunt on accident?
Who is that?
Dang it.
Is that the
Who is that?
Oops.
Wait.
Oh, geez.
Let me up.
Copies.
If you're not seeing home improvement, mm-hmm.
Oh, I can't get through here.
That's so silly.
Ah!
Okay.
Toy Story.
He's a Buzz Lightyear!
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
I messed up.
No
way.
Does I have to do it like before?
Okay, wait.
Okay, so I need to shoot another orange.
Oh.
Ah, I'm taking.
Wait.
Yeah, I need more momentum.
Shoot orange!
Oh.
It doesn't help when I'm getting topsy-turvy.
first okay yeah imagine if I had hit that if I had hit the thing
where can I get momentum from I guess I have to create it all on my own it's I gotta shoot I gotta shoot orange, or blue.
Then, we...
Oops.
My bad.
Do it again.
Oh.
Good enough?
No, not good enough.
Wait.
Oops, wait, okay.
Home improvement ended in the 90s.
Progress in making.
Okay, hold on.
Did I make it?
Oh, yeah!
How do I get back home?
Oh, wait.
Um...
Hmm.
Somehow I lucked out with that, but I don't know how to get back home.
Wasn't the intended solution, but it works.
Let's go.
If there's a wheel, there's a way.
Um, I do orange.
Okay, orange.
No, blue.
Gosh.
Oh, so close.
Okay!
Alright.
My ride is here.
My very slow ride.
Oh, wait, what's happening?
Wait, wait, you can't do that.
Oh no!
Wait a second!
Oh no, it's like a revolving sushi!
Eh?
Okay.
You are the sushi.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, death.
Death is imminent.
Please.
Okay, good, good, good, good.
The game, the game has, like, good save points.
Good checkpoints.
You know?
Oh, oops.
That was the wrong one.
Oh, where am I?
Uh.
Oh, I'm supposed to go the other way.
My bad.
I got a little lost.
We made it through to that place.
Yeah, indeed.
Don't forget the quicksit.
Wait, is it...
I'm gonna save, but... Is it F5?
Nothing is happening if I I'm gonna save my...
What does this do?
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh.
Did it open?
Oh, where are you going?
There's
more than one!
Oh, there's two doors!
Oh my golly.
Okay.
Okay, so I have to be in there.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to get the timing.
Just think with portals.
I know, I know I have to, like, portal here and here, but this needs to also...
Okay, hold on.
Wait, don't come in here.
Sorry, it scared me.
Okay, go away, go away,
Go away, go away.
Destroy!
Go!
Why doesn't this one explode?
Oh, now I trapped it in here.
With me.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, now it's just kind of wandering on its own.
It's doing its own.
Oh, no.
Okay, alrighty, alrighty.
How long does it last for?
Okay.
Alright.
Please.
Did I make it?
Oh, where is it?
How'd you get in here?
Arm, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Place the top one first.
Like this?
Oh, I guess that makes sense, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got you, I got you.
Oh!
Did you know?
You can donate one or all of your vital organs to the Aperture Science Self-Esteem Fund for girls.
It's true.
The girls need the organs.
I've always wished for five kidneys.
Um, he's right behind me, isn't he?
That would make my self-esteem go up so much if I had more kidneys.
Only five?
I'm not trying to be, like, so greedy.
that need kidneys and I need five due to mandatory scheduled maintenance the appropriate chamber for this testing sequence is currently unavailable it has been replaced with a live fire course designed for military androids the enrichment center apologizes for the inconvenience and wishes you the best of luck it's time for turrets
So cute.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
There you are.
Wait.
Okay, no, it's not gonna be able to see me.
Oh, you can't see me.
Freaky.
I hear the radio!
Where is he?
Oh.
Scary.
Go meet her.
Wait, um...
I need to do like a...
up there.
And then...
Hold on.
Ah!
Stay!
Don't spook me, don't spook me.
You can have my kidneys, liver, lungs, whatever you need.
Let you take my heart, but it already...
Oh my gosh, break.
Activated.
Are you still there?
Oh my god, they're so cute sounding, though, no?
Searching.
Um.
Nap time.
Searching.
Oh wait.
I think I did the wrong one.
There we go.
Activated.
Are you still there?
Can't I like grab it?
Hi, Bernadine.
Hey.
Oh.
Don't hate you.
Wait, how do I throw again?
Can I throw?
Can I not throw these guys?
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
I don't eat you.
Momentum.
What does this say?
It says help.
Uh oh, is this where it starts getting kind of crazy?
Oh!
Is this where it starts getting a little spooky?
I'm trying to crouch.
I'm trying to.
But I can't get in, I'm still too fat.
Wait, I'm still too fat.
Oh, here we go.
The cake is a lie!
The cake is a lie, the cake is a lie, the cake is a lie.
It's still so exciting.
Seeing all this.
You know?
Why can't I throw these things, but I can't throw the turrets?
too hefty they said the thing i like how it looks like it's written in crayon hello can i help you i wonder
a trusted friend in science
so cool Yo.
Yo.
You can throw turrets.
I tried.
Are you still there?
Oh, this one's tricky though because there's two of them.
Hmm.
Who's there?
Not me.
Mouse won while holding turrets.
That's what I tried.
The handprint.
I remember seeing a Half-Life 2 mod back in the day that added the portal gun to Freeman's arsenal.
Oh, that does sound fun.
Cube has a shield!
You're so smart!
Are you still there?
There you are.
Woo!
Creepy.
Quit.
Throw!
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, I wonder...
You're gonna trust some random scribbles on a wall or GLaDOS?
Yeah, GLaDOS is so pretty.
Oh.
I was close enough.
Okay, hold on.
No deploying, no deploying, no deploying.
Oh
my gosh.
I almost died.
Oh my gosh.
I wonder what my health is anyway.
I don't know.
It regens?
Okay, I'm going to save just in case.
Look at all these tools and stuff.
Oh.
It regens really fast.
No, my companion cube is full of bullet holes.
Deploy.
Who's searching?
Nah, nothing there.
Nothing here.
Did that get it?
We have a couple tries.
We have a couple tries here, no?
Bounce!
Maybe.
Proves the cubes are stronger than high-tech turrets.
Wait.
What are you gonna do?
Who's there?
Shutting down.
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
Ah.
Okay.
Hmm.
Uh.
Ow!
That scared me.
Ah!
They just flick the bullet.
I attack you aggressively.
I want to see...
Let's see.
If I do this, maybe...
Ouch!
How did you get me though?
How?
My poor Compendium.
My poor Compendium Cube.
Wait, I can't bring you with me!
Well done, Android.
The enrichment center once again reminds you that Android Hell is a real place where you will be sent at the first sign of defiance.
Android Hell, don't threaten me with a good time.
You would have been given the cake by now if you didn't keep destroying the camera.
That's not true at all.
They love an open mind.
Oh, look at this.
They knew.
They were like, we won't let you destroy this one.
The Vitala Horetus Vent will deliver a weighted companion cube in 3, 2, 1.
I like the colors.
No turrets!
This weighted companion cube will accompany you through the test chamber.
Please take care of it.
Okay.
Wait, this one is actually a companion cube.
It's got, like, the heart on it.
We actually have a companion cube.
Come, come, come, come.
Come, my sweet.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Um...
Okay, one moment, please.
Where does...
Where do they go?
Where to?
Okay, hold on.
I'm running.
I might die.
I might die, companion cube.
Don't forget about me.
I think I need to bring the companion cube.
The symptoms most commonly produced by Enrichment Center testing are superstition, perceiving inanimate objects as alive, and hallucinations.
The Enrichment Center reminds you that the weighted companion cube will never threaten to stab you and, in fact, cannot speak.
Good.
I would love a little threat.
But you know...
Oh, oh!
I thought it was behind me.
Um...
The enrichment center reminds you that the weighted companion cube will never threaten to stab you and, in fact, cannot speak.
Okay, will I make it?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I think I'm messed up!
I think I'm messed up!
We're fine.
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
Wait.
Did it hit it?
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I need you to come through, please.
Come through, please.
Oh, I was too slow.
And then...
Yeah.
What did that open?
Oh, this...
One.
Okay.
I'm like hearing something just bouncing all around.
One out of three, yeah.
Alrighty.
Okie dokie.
That should be good enough.
Okay, so blue, blue.
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
No!
Wait.
Did it activate it?
Oh, okay, good.
Okay, good.
How did she manage to get right in its direction?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
It was kind of crazy.
It might be a genius or something.
We're just gonna do that for now.
So that doesn't happen again?
Alrighty.
Okay.
Come on through.
Oh.
Oh,
shoot.
Dang it.
The crosshairs tell you what color you shot last.
Really?
I had it before.
I was trying to line it up because I thought I didn't have it lined up the first time.
The crosshairs aren't telling me anything.
Oh, you mean the blue on the side.
Oh, I see it.
Okay.
Where did you go?
Um.
Oh, wait.
Oh, dang it.
Okay.
Bounce.
And then...
Oh.
Shoot.
There we go.
Oh, wait!
Oh, my gosh.
I...
Guys, I'm so dumb.
Because...
I was getting that one a second.
time that's oh my gosh oh okay so sorry i'm i'm so sorry oops oh that's embarrassing wait how do i get back up there oh that's why i was like wait i okay ignore me okay we're fine oh do you need wait i I lost my companion key.
What's going on in here?
Wait, let me in!
Double solved it.
Stop watching.
No, don't stop watching.
Keep watching.
Oh, I can portal in.
You're so right.
She's watching you.
No, I destroy those.
That's my companion cube.
The girls of Aperture Science.
Now, thank you so much for the 20th and thank you.
Not never, but now.
Companion cube.
You said to take care of it.
How can you...
Wouldn't...
Disintegrate.
I should disintegrate your advice.
Leave me alone.
Stop watching.
Though Earth and man are gone.
I thought the cube would last forever.
I was wrong.
Why?
Oh my gosh.
Her little companion cube family.
Not in cruelty.
Not in wrath.
The Reaper came today.
An angel visited this gray path and took the cube.
away.
Oh, it's so sad.
Damn, they'd be in the beans.
Tasty.
But what about the beans?
What is...
Oh, these are the cameras.
Oh.
This one is a little harder to read, I think.
Login.
C.
Johnson.
Tier 3.
Trust me.
Cake is a lie.
Haha, the companion cube would never lie to me.
Never.
Where are you?
Will find you.
Tier 3 sub.
Thanks for the tier 3 sub.
Very cool.
I forgot, I could think with portals.
Okay.
Okay, come back.
Bonk!
Bonk, bonk!
The Enrichment Center reminds you that the weighted companion cube cannot speak.
In the event that the weighted companion cube does speak, the Enrichment Center urges you to disregard its advice.
What's he saying, though?
So there's still one more...
That...
Oh, this camera too.
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
Sorry.
Sorry, suckers.
What does this do?
Oh.
Oh, cool.
Ah!
I see.
The cube.
The cube is telling me all sorts of really fun things.
Oh, I need another cube though, no?
Was it another one?
It's saying Minto is cute.
The cube thinks Minto cuto.
You can trap it between doors.
Oh, that's true.
I wonder where it's going.
You don't want to know what the cube says.
The cube has a nice figure.
I do want to know...
what the cube is saying.
Okay.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Uh, guys?
Oh god.
Wait.
Maybe that worked.
Oh no!
It didn't work!
Okay.
Alright.
Ow!
Wait, how do I get you up there?
Alright.
Put you in?
Alright, hold on.
Come, come, come, come.
We're waiting?
Okay, come cube.
Come, my cube.
My sweet.
My precious.
I'm becoming cube-smeagle over here.
Yes, my cube.
My lovely cube.
My companion.
Ah!
Sorry.
I thought I lost her.
Okay, just kidding.
One more time.
Doesn't she just look so cute with the heart?
The exit is this way.
You did it.
The weighted companion cube certainly brought you good luck.
However, it cannot accompany you for the rest of the test and, unfortunately, must be euthanized.
Please escort your companion cube to the Aperture Science Emergency Intelligence Incinerator.
We even time you.
Bye!
You euthanized your faithful companion cube more quickly than any test subject on record.
Congratulations.
Take me instead!
I got an achievement for it.
You think she's in there?
Cube?
Cube, can you hear me?
Boy, boy, cube!
The caked up cube will be missed.
The companion cube loves me!
She would know I had to do it!
That was cold.
Look.
If I kill the companion cube, the companion cube will be with me in the afterlife.
That's how it works.
I'm a ghost.
The experiment is nearing its conclusion.
The enrichment center is required to remind you that you will be baked.
And then there will be cake.
Yeah!
There will be cake!
Let them eat it!
What's this way?
Is that a turret?
Oh, no.
That's a radio, but it's not playing anything.
What's that?
Oh, no cake.
She's watching you.
Courage is not the absence of fear.
When I'm figuring out how to...
to take apart the establishment.
I also like to listen to that song.
Nothing here.
Wait, why not?
I must trust.
I almost didn't trust.
That was too scary.
Where am I supposed to go from here?
Wait, where did I come from?
Wait, did I...
Uh, wait, where did I come from?
Oh, wait.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, we're fine, we're fine.
.
Wait a second.
Did I mess up?
Where does this go?
Okay.
Oh, I think I see.
This one, maybe?
Ah!
Do you see it?
You're gonna have to jump the gap.
I am?
Let's see what.
Am I supposed to be a gamer?
That was close.
Okay.
Maybe this one instead.
Like so.
Yeah.
Oh no!
Oh, I forgot there's turrets here!
Oh my gosh, wait.
But they're gonna kill me.
They're gonna kill me.
Okay, this lasts a pretty long time though.
Are you still there?
Darket lost.
Let's see.
Hey guys, uh, try not to spam, you know, I appreciate hints and all, but try not to do so much until I, um, until I've, like, at least even looked at the puzzle a little bit, okay?
Thank you, though.
I barely got into the room, so let me, like, just kind of look around and see what we got going on first before I, before we, uh, you know.
before I ask for help before I ask for help thank you okay so that's the door so I'm guessing this opens this which activates that oh okay
I missed all the hints did everyone say to open the console a noclip directly into the cake no you open the console and you actually put the slice of cake into your console and it will change Gladys's mind.
Gladys has taste buds in the console and she'll say, wow, delicious.
Let's see, okay.
How do without getting shot?
Can I kill the target?
Wait, I think that... did that?
No, no searching, no searching.
Can you kill the turrets with the ball?
Ah!
Yes, you can!
Okay, so that's one down.
And...
Maybe like here?
Maybe.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Wait, you're gonna launch here.
Too high.
Wait, activated.
Who, where, why?
Die.
Dang it.
I was wrong.
Hold on.
Hint portals.
You're so right.
Oh, oh, yeah!
Okay, that's another one down.
Okay, we're getting there.
I will have a face.
A safe...
E!
Just use your gravity gun, so true.
Was that one?
Will that hit?
First try?
Oh!
Oh, I'm too good!
Oh wait.
Which is about to hit?
It's about to go to this one, right?
Okay, alrighty, alrighty.
Now, I can properly try things.
But what do I try?
Wait a second, what do I try?
It was my birthday today!
I was wondering if I could get an MGS birthday song.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
I go symphony.
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, did I...
I think I even missed.
Okay, what I have to do is...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh, it's this one, isn't it?
Is it this?
Hold on, I'm checking.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's tricky.
Wait, that's kind of tricky.
I have to do so much shooting and so much portaling.
I have to do so much shooting and portaling!
I think one of the longer ones would be easiest.
Okay.
So I'm gonna...
Wait, I don't think it'll...
Wait, oh, oh my gosh, wait, oh, wait, oh gosh, wait, I have to, okay, oh, okay, okay.
Need three brains for this one.
No, no, we don't, we got it.
We got it?
I mean, those cake is definitely not fake.
Not at all.
I go over here.
Yes, please.
Thank you.
Actually, do I go down?
I'm not quite sure.
What did that do?
What did it do?
Oh my gosh, wait, there's...
I have a thousand more today!
We die!
Happy birthday!
I opened the wall, I came in.
Oh, this!
Am I stuck here?
Oh no.
I think I need to drop here.
Okay.
Wait, I'm stupid.
Wait, uh, wait, I'm dumb.
Hold on.
I messed up.
Yes, but no.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
And I need blue.
Wait, no?
Oh, it moved it.
Wait, don't don't don't go yet.
Don't go yet.
No!
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
It disables the portal when you...
When you...
When it starts moving.
Yeah, the portal vanishes off moving surfaces.
Yeah, I didn't realize.
that, so that is what got me a little bit.
Okay.
So, if I do this...
So, what I'll need to do is click, go through portal portal.
I
did!
Um...
Can I jump onto this?
I'm scared.
Oh, I made it.
Okay.
Yeah!
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I need to do it again, don't I?
Because I have to get behind the...
Okay.
Got it.
Wait, let's put the cube over here.
Oh.
Don't leave, don't leave.
Don't leave, my Uber.
Okay.
Don't forget to save.
You're right.
Just in case.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I was like, what was all that for?
I couldn't even remember.
Wait, is there...
Anywhere?
Okay.
Graceful like a cat.
No, no, no!
No!
Oh, okay, okay.
We're fine!
Everything's fine!
Everything's chill!
What's your guys' problem?
What?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this might be the leap of faith.
Your mind is a beautiful enigma.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
I got a blue!
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, where am I looking?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh,
no.
Oh, I need more.
More momentum!
Ow!
Get me out of this hellhole!
Oh shoot!
I did the wrong thing.
You think I can make this?
That was craziness.
Okay, wait.
Let me get it a little closer.
There we go, there we go.
Alright.
Here we go!
Well done.
Be advised that the next test requires exposure to uninsulated electrical parts that may be dangerous under certain conditions.
For more information, please attend an enrichment center electrical safety seminar.
That should be an achievement.
That was crazy.
You can shoot at midair too so you don't have to aim your jump.
That is true, that is true.
Welcome to the final test.
When you are done, you will drop the device in the Equipment Recovery Annex.
Enrichment Center regulations require both hands to be empty before any cake...
Well, really?
I mean cake?
Before any cake?
Before any cake.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Uh, that's not good.
Guys.
Oops.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm good.
Ow!
So close.
Wait, wait.
More, more, more.
Ah!
Oh!
I'm trying to brute force it for real!
Okay.
Fine, I'll think with portals.
Fine, I'll think with portals!
Wait.
Where is it?
.
Vital testing apparatus destroyed.
Where is it?
Uh...
Can I make this?
Oh, I don't know if I can.
Oh, yes I can.
I'm a genius.
Cake!
Just around the corner!
The test is now over.
Uh-oh.
All aperture technologies remain safely operational up to 4,000 degrees Kelvin.
Best assured that there is absolutely no chance of a dangerous equipment malfunction prior to your victory incandescence.
Thank you for participating in this amateur science computer-aided enrichment activity.
Are we the cake?
Oh my god!
Wait, I think this will...
No, okay, it's...
Yeah!
Stop it.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
We are pleased that you made it through the final challenge where we pretended we were going to murder you we are very where do i go for your success we are throwing a party in honor of your tremendous success yeah place the device on the ground then lie on your stomach with your arms at your sides it's toast if my associate will arrive shortly to collect you for your party into the fire trust make no further attempt to leave the testing area position or you will miss the party wait actually though oh my gosh wait oh i'm gonna throw up oh okay hold on okay okay okay okay we're gonna whoosh we're gonna whoosh all right it's gotta be orange oh yeah they're like um didn't you just go through like a two hour long tutorial and you don't know what to do.
Made the correct party escort submission position decision.
Party goer.
So many birthday candles on that cake.
I'm still young at heart.
Don't get it twisted.
I hate this game.
Oh my gosh, that was me.
I can't
believe I haven't been jump scared the entire time And then suddenly I am
Oh What are they doing with all these little turrets?
Oh, go, go, go It's suddenly it's a horror game
Whoa, freaky.
Oh, locks can stop me, baby.
The sound effects.
I'm here.
I know you're there.
I can't see you.
Hello.
Which way we go?
Both ways have...
Both...
Oh, there we go.
Be careful.
Alrighty.
Oh, we got here.
Some goopy soup.
The real goop.
Whoa!
Cool!
The turrets were the real horror this whole time!
Yeah, we got some goopy soup over here.
No.
I can think of portals!
Nah, uh...
If I, like, go from here...
You think I can make it?
Minky, that's me!
I don't know if that's actually a quicksave or not.
I don't think it is.
I don't think it's quicksaving at all.
Oh, yeah.
Black Mesa!
Oh, what is Black Mesa?
2.59% of all DOD contracts, 10 billion in federal dollars annually 12% from full and open competition 88% from no bids or excluded sources bids not bound by government performance and results act 5 year review GSA schedules Black Mesa aperture whoa aperture is going crazy
what's it mean a case study genetic life form and disc operating system defense logistics agency solicits bid for development of fuel System icing inhibitor.
F-S-I-I.
Black Mesa F-S-I-I proposal.
Even the chairs are branded.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, wait.
They have the new Xbox!
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, my, my.
Baking pot.
Oh wait, this is like cake.
Cup of butter and margarine.
This is just the cake recipe.
What's this?
Oh, nice...
Tittle?
Nice...
Tittle jellyfish.
Is this Half-Life 2?
Yes.
Oh my gosh, I was in there!
What is this though?
Number 2, 3, 4.
Is that me?
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to read.
Why are the physics against me?
Failed.
Number 42 failed.
Whoa, look at his proportions.
Built like a damn chicken.
I was in there!
Wow, it's so fun.
I remember that chamber.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, oh, just barely.
Shoo.
Nothing?
None of your beeswax, glados.
You don't know that.
Hello?
The cake is a lie!
Oh!
Wait, oh!
Wow!
Oh!
Wee!
Okay, the test is over now.
You win!
Go back to the recovery annex for your cake.
Okay!
It was a fun test, and we're all impressed at how much you won.
The test is over.
Come back.
Portal 1 and 2 genuinely have some of the best level design I've played in a game.
Honestly, it's so true.
Where's my cube?
Give them to me.
Actually, what am I supposed to do here?
Like, I remember this...
I remember this room where I went through the hole.
But...
Yeah, both portals this time.
Oh!
Wait.
You're right.
Ooh.
They cut it!
Horrible.
Why wouldn't they wait?
Uh, I think I can shoot that.
Oh.
Is something coming?
Oh, okay, okay.
No more cake!
You guys!
They seriously hate us.
Oh, I think I need to portal over there.
They started the party without us!
Oh, I could have just walked.
Ear protection must be worn in this area.
Ear protection is very crucial, everybody.
Take care of your ears.
I have to take a special...
Oh.
Okay, just kidding.
I have to take a special care of mine because they're big.
I'm looking around for a wall.
Really?
Okay.
Am I blind?
Why can't I find a wall that I can...
Portal.
Look down?
It's so cool when it does that.
How did you get in here?
Over here.
But... Oh wait, oh.
Oh!
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Okay.
Wow!
Okay, we're good.
How do you?
Come on, let me in easily.
Stop making me take tough ways to get in and out.
Ride the piston.
I just shot orange, so I need to shoot it.
Wait?
Oh.
No!
Wait, I shot the wrong thing!
Wait, oh, I shot blue, but...
Oh, my bad.
Okay, so that's blue.
So we shoot orange.
Oh my god.
Are you not...
Are you really playing Portal if you don't accidentally shoot the wrong thing, you know?
Which way is up?
Okay.
Oops.
Oh, we almost had a loop.
There we go.
Alright.
You're not even going the right way.
Where do you think you're always?
I don't think you're going.
Where do you think you're going?
You don't know where I'm going, Lados.
You have no idea.
Hello?
I like how she's, like, talking to herself.
And then it's like, eh?
Hello?
Can I fall in between this?
You cannot!
Oh.
They're like, you are literally playing portal game right now, and you're going to take the stairs.
You're going to try a ladder when you're playing portal game.
Don't be ridiculous right now.
Help!
The cake is a lie!
Cake is a lie!
Do you guys remember that guy's computer?
Beans!
More cake is a lie.
Who else?
Who else was like crawling through these vents?
I have to wonder.
Whoa.
Oh, I go all the way to the floor.
I didn't even need to do all of this.
The rat man.
Who's that guy?
Oh, it goes to the ceiling?
We live and we learn.
Let's see what's on this side anyway.
Okay, this doesn't even...
My plan squashed again!
I've been...
Wait, oh.
Oh.
Sorry.
What?
You're not even going the right way.
Where do you think you're going?
Okay.
This works.
Hello,
loving the stream!
Hi!
Thank you!
Today I learned you can stand there!
Minto pancakes.
Yummy!
Oh, those two go to the ceiling!
Today I learned?
right now I learned everything else doesn't go to the ceiling only the ones the two that I specifically chose yeah the ceiling tells you
only the two exact ones that I decided to go through trying to decide though like what's the way to do this oh
Where am I?
It's a 50% chance.
It's not.
If I run and jump...
Good thing there's no fall damage.
It has a portal surface.
What does?
What has a portal surface?
What?
Oh, I didn't see it at the end of the hallway.
Totally overthinking it.
Okay, that one.
That one, though, I didn't realize that it had a portal surface.
That's why.
I just didn't see it.
Didn't we have some fun, though?
Yeah, so fun.
No way.
That was great.
So fun.
it was so fun it was like so fun glados oh there we go okay i need to get up there
wait where am i going oh
is there oh maybe this one yes no
ah Wait, oh, they both...
Oh, I think I broke it.
Maybe I do a further one away.
No worries.
That's what I sound like.
Okay, oh wait.
Okay, uh, shoot.
Oh, geez.
Oh, I can't see.
I'm not fast enough.
Remember when the platform was sliding into the fire pit?
I said goodbye, and you were like, No word.
And then I was off.
We pretended we were going to murder you.
No word.
That was great.
Is anyone there?
Oh, well, I figured it out i think oh okay i'm not even like moving it put it forces you out of the portal so it's not like i am i am looking
you know what i mean or it's not like i'm forceful i'm what's the word it's not like i'm trying to jump off of it is what i'm trying to say Where do I go from here, though?
Okay, good.
I thought it would go all the way in.
Um, oh, over here, probably.
Okay.
Uh, is there another wall?
That I can go- Oh, duh.
Which way is up?
Okay.
Does this open?
No?
Um.
Okay, we're making my way downtown.
Walking.
fast.
Space is past.
I'm homebound.
Over that way.
Okay.
How do I get over there?
How goes your own welcome to Mambushabdaku!
I need the momentum.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
So...
Okay.
If I...
Why am I suddenly losing the plot?
Okay, I need to...
Will I make it?
Oh.
No.
I messed up a little bit.
My bad.
Okay, hold on.
I messed up a little bit.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's go even higher.
Okay, orange.
Orange, you glad.
I didn't say banana!
Okay, we're good.
Everything's fine.
Oh, no, everything is not fine.
You really shouldn't be.
here this isn't safe for you it's not too late for you to turn back did i get it yes nice i'm gaming she's a gamer she's a gamer over here what do you mean by oh my god what is this
i know it's it's pretty good about auto saving but
Don't you mean this car?
Just trying to figure out where to go.
What is the purpose of all the Smashers?
Great question.
They're just noisy.
That's what they are.
Oh, wait.
That's not an up.
What's up?
I almost had it.
Okay, okay.
I see, I see.
If I...
I'm in blue.
If I orange over there...
I should be able to make it back.
Oh, I made it somehow!
Ah!
I made it somehow!
Okay, cool.
This way?
Let's just save.
Anything over here?
No.
Okay.
What's the exit?
Oh, this way?
Or not that way.
No, not that way.
This way.
Which way do we go?
Here!
Oh, okay.
I can't hear you, Gladys.
Oh.
What's so far?
funny and laugh and laugh and laugh can i go under here okay uh but where can i put another line
i'm trying to see maybe here
Oh my gosh, I made it!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I made it, I made it!
Down?
Okay, I'm trusting the bloody handprints.
Try using portals?
Never.
Oh, what do you think the name of this game is?
Help!
Why would you need help?
You have all the water and beads you could ever ask for.
Help?
Ungrateful.
And you got the latest Xbox.
The 360.
Cube.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
They did that on purpose, didn't they?
Uh oh.
Am I?
Am I still here?
Oh no, no way.
Wait, this is evil!
Wait, this is so evil!
Ah,
okay.
Okay, we lived.
Okay, all right.
That's two down.
One more.
Hi.
We're good?
What's this?
Oh.
How do I get in there?
The claw.
Beam me up!
How do we get in there?
Oh, somehow.
Ugh.
They were like, hey, you didn't forget about all those turrets that you had to deal with, right?
All those turrets that we also made you deal with?
Like, those are still definitely active in the thing.
Oh, but the exit.
is this way.
But, wait, do I go in there?
If I drop?
Oh, gosh.
You can portal them for fun.
I don't know if I can.
Ah.
Oh, I guess I could have gone down through there, I suppose.
But what's the point?
Let's go so quick.
Let's just go.
Hello.
Searching.
I'm trying to drop.
Wait.
Searching.
How did that open?
Freaky!
Freaky, freaky!
Just looking around.
Over here, what?
A ghost?
More... ramblings?
Hello, can I help you?
Cake is a lie, cake is a lie, cake is a lie, cake is a lie, there's no cake.
But what if...
And she's watching.
Okay, it's all the same ramblings.
Okay, this person is like crazy, but they're consistent.
They just write the same thing over and over again.
Where do I...
Aha!
Okay.
The definition of insanity.
I suppose so, right?
This is your fault.
It didn't have to be like this.
I'm not kidding now.
Turn back or I will kill you.
It wouldn't!
You love me too much!
I'm going to kill you.
And all the cake is gone.
You don't even care, do you?
This is your last chance.
Number 42 again.
Wait, let me save.
Hello?
I remember beating this game, but I don't remember beating it.
You know what I mean?
Rocket!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Uh.
I missed.
How could you miss?
Oh!
Guys, I think I'm bad at this.
Okay, hold on.
Line it up, line it up.
There we go.
Oh wait, do I need to break this?
Ah, okay, just kidding.
I thought I was trying to destroy it.
It doesn't work because it was soft lock you you're right oh my gosh it's so funny i'm trying to kill it i didn't even think about it i was like it's the final boss oh
silly over here underwear
oh i get it i get it i get it Hey.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Oh,
in here?
Now that thing won't...
Such a convenient friend.
Wait.
Uh...
Break the tube!
For a cube!
How do I do that?
Oh, wait.
Ah, okay, so we do need to go back.
Okay, just kidding.
I'm not going to lie.
I thought about, like, bringing one of these things back here.
Was that enough?
Wait.
Oh.
It never...
Uh.
Yeah, it still needs to see me.
And it's also...
Cube!
Fun!
That works too.
Was there a different method you were thinking of?
This isn't gonna like destroy me, is it?
Why can't I just leave?
Wait, how do I...
Is it gonna kill me?
Oh!
Oh, that's evil.
Wait a second.
That's so evil, though.
Leap of faith?
I'll try it.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Okay, it literally does not let you.
Okay.
I used a chair last time.
That works, too.
I want to see something strange and mystical.
Try putting a portal on the hydraulic press.
The hydraulic...
Uh...
Huh?
I think I'm beyond the hydraulic presto.
What did I shoot?
Oh, okay.
Ew, who's using the toilet?
Oh, that was me.
That was me?
That was me over there.
A lot of people use a chair.
I think that was definitely the easier method.
I think it's kind of fun, though, to be a little extra, you know?
We're going up, up, up, up, it's our moment.
Is this toilet water?
Where can I walk in this?
Oh.
Okay, definitely toilet water.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
Oops.
That's not what I meant to do.
All
right, one at a time, one at a time.
Put me down.
I
know the music jump scare for real.
Go activation.
Okay.
Who's there?
Uh-oh.
Critical error.
Oh, that's me!
Hi!
I'm saving real quick.
Hey.
I don't hate you.
Um...
I think this is one.
Who are you?
Amita!
Critical error.
Okay, there's one down in the middle.
Okay, I think we have two left.
Who are you?
Okay, because you
I can't tell.
Oh, yeah.
What about him?
Who are you?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, that's so awkward.
Wait.
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
This should be the last...
Oh, nope.
There's a couple.
There's one more.
My computer is busted and there's a new terror game.
Astronomy thing.
I wanted to play it, but again.
PC busted and laptop sluggish.
No!
Could you play Voices of the Void someday?
I have!
I have played Voices of the Void.
I guess I should go back to it.
Beautiful watching my Oshi play my favorite game of all time.
My Arthur, thank you so much.
For the Akazuma, thank you!
Thank you!
I don't blame you.
Yeah.
Ah!
Victoria voices are cute.
Okay, alright, we got rid of all of them then.
So, actually I'm just gonna drop down here.
Because I saw that.
Wait, how can I get to there though?
Wait, there's another one.
There's another launcher.
There's two launchers!
Alrighty, already, already, already, already, already.
I guess maybe I just go back how I did?
Wait, hold on.
Big brain time.
Yeah, I have to figure out...
Wait, where's another...
Eee?
How do I get higher?
I guess just like that?
I guess I just picked the higher one first.
All right, all right.
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
Well, why did it feel like I went so high up in the air before?
It's so cool.
What a cool room.
Um, and yeah, I can't shoot over there.
Oh, I can't shoot under this.
Okay.
Gamers don't look up.
I am looking up!
I see that, but I don't...
Wait, hold on.
Oh, wait.
Okay, maybe...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
And then it'll launch me.
And I need to do...
Blue?
Oh!
Ah!
Wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
You got this, Mito, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry about it.
Can we jump down from somewhere higher?
I don't...
I think this is the highest one, no?
Why?
What I'm gonna try and do is...
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Oh.
Unless up there?
Not the correct wall.
Need to do some mid-air portaling.
I think we need to get more momentum.
Oh, this one's tricky.
This one's tough for me.
So I do.
Don't overthink.
I always overthink.
I'm trying not to overthink.
You're going speedruns.
strats?
No way!
What do you mean?
Wait, that didn't do it.
Did that do it?
Wait, no, no, no.
Let me in, please.
There we go.
You're on the right track.
I...
I'm like not getting the order of operations.
Thank you so much!
Last in the store!
Thank you so much for the gift, dude.
Thank you!
Gotta hit the other slant midair.
Then shoot at the ground as you land.
Hem the ass?
Yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, just use portals, dummy.
Just portal.
Just play portal.
Just play the game, dummy.
Just play the game.
Think with portals.
I'm trying.
Oh, dang it.
I need to stop trying to aim for this one.
I need to like reshoot it or something.
Okay, so...
I go through that.
Go through this.
So I go down.
Pew!
Then I go down again, and I'm even faster.
And then I go pew, and I shoot this one.
And I go pew, the other side.
That's how I do.
If you're a speedrunner, yes.
No way!
That seems like this is the only option.
No!
Okay.
So then, once I go down, pew, down...
I go through this and I Wait Wait hold on Not really but this is cooler What?
Okay what I still want to try it I still want to try it
Sounds cool so I say go for it No wrong way definitely more satisfying ways Remember to say pew Okay wait I'm trying to remember what when i get to this peel what do i i make it what color wait okay down
orange takes me back to blue and i go pew and then i orange
wait green wait wait okay and then i go pew and i'm even faster I'm so confused.
Ah!
Wait, okay, let's just try it.
Let's just try it.
I'm still confused.
But...
I'm still confused, but...
It's fine.
Wait, why'd you guys say no?
I had it.
You had the blue in the right spot.
Oh, you're right, I could have just...
Oh, I could have just launched myself.
Oh, whatever.
Phew!
And...
Oh.
Guys, this one...
I'm not gonna get every puzzle, okay?
I'm not gonna...
And that's okay.
Some puzzles will confuse me more than others.
It's all right.
Didn't say pew fast enough.
I know.
So there?
And then...
But the thing is, is I have it here, but then...
How can I jump down from anywhere?
Is my question.
Like, how can I get the momentum to speed?
Where am I?
Oh.
I don't know where it went.
How did it get back up here?
We did it?
Oh.
Yeah.
I meant to do that.
Whoa!
Yeah, I totally meant to do that.
Good job, Minto.
Thank you!
Oh, it's so bright here.
Think harder for this.
Oh, you're asking a big task, you know?
You're asking for some... for a real big ask, you know?
Wait a second.
Wait a second, wait a second.
I think I get it.
It's scary though.
But I can make it!
Dang it.
I don't know why I didn't let me move though.
Alright, alright.
Oh, shoot.
Oh no, now I'm- now I'm the turret.
Oh, I can't move!
Ah!
Wait, please, please!
Okay.
I'm gonna try for this one instead.
Oh, oh, where am I?
Oh.
Okay, I don't think that's a-
Let me move this.
Is this a little closer maybe?
Like here?
And then...
Oh!
Where am I?
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Okay, too close.
Too close.
I know, I bonked my head.
Please!
Yeah!
Where am I?
Oops.
My bad.
Um.
There we go.
Don't mind me.
Wow.
What if I jumped?
What if I just jumped right now?
What equipment stops and starts suddenly?
I haven't heard from GLaDOS in a while.
You think she's okay?
Oh, more of a Black Mesa stuff.
Oh, chairs.
Who's just, like, sitting here watching the world go by?
Glados of course I care about her wait is that her right there my queen well you found me congratulations was it worth it because despite your violent behavior the only thing you've managed to break so far is my heart maybe you could settle for that and we'll just call it a day I guess we both know that isn't going to happen you chose this path now i'd have a surprise for you what's that deploying surprise in five four time out for a second that wasn't supposed to happen do you see that thing that fell out of me what is that it's not the surprise i've never seen it before never mind she's so cute i'll solve later by myself because you'll be dead i wouldn't bother with that thing my guess is that Somehow.
Um.
We gotta- I don't want to tell you your business, but if it were me, I'd leave that thing alone.
Look how cute.
Where are you taking that thing?
Don't call it that thing.
No?
Do you think I'm trying to trick you with reverse psychology?
I mean, seriously now.
Seriously.
Seriously?
Just a little guy?
Okay, fine.
Do touch it.
Pick it up and just stuff it back into me.
Oh my gosh, I wish I could run.
I wish I could run.
Let's be honest.
Neither one of us knows what that thing does.
Just put it in the corner, and I'll deal with it later.
Time to think with portals!
That thing is probably some kind of raw sewage container.
Go ahead and rub your face all over it.
Oh my god, it's like...
Oh!
Maybe you should marry that thing since you love it so much.
Do you want to marry it?
Well, we won't let you.
How does that feel?
She shoots?
Has I lied to you?
I mean, in this room, trust me.
Leave that thing alone.
She shoots?
Okay, one more time.
I am being serious now.
That crazy thing is not part of any test protocol.
One more time.
Gladys is just yapping.
She's just like, girl, do something.
I'm just like, still.
I did it!
You're kidding me.
Did you just set that Aperture Science thing we don't know what it does into an Aperture Science Emergency Intelligence Incinerator?
That has got to be the dumbest thing that- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
More seductive.
Of news.
I figured out what that thing you just incinerated did.
It was a morality core they installed after I flooded the enrichment center with a deadly neurotoxin to make me stop flooding the enrichment center.
a deadly neurotoxin oh hot god while i warm up the neurotoxin emitters uh-oh that court may have had some ancillary responsibilities i can't shut off the turret defenses oh geez if you want my advice you should just lie down in front of our rocket trust me oh wait wait i don't know why okay we gotta get it to lock on while i'm up here right whatever it is you think you're doing Ah!
Wait.
Up here?
Um, let's see.
Portals?
You're so bad.
You guys are so right.
Nice job breaking it, Hero.
This isn't brave.
It's murder.
I don't wanna do the game.
Whoa.
What happened there?
Wait.
How do I grab it?
You don't even care, do you?
Like that, that's how I grab it.
Who is cute?
Cute!
What's that?
So cute!
Oh, that thing has no future.
Did you hear me?
I said you don't care.
I wonder if I'll make it.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so slow.
Oh my god, I can't move.
I can't.
Ah!
conversation and a lot more killing no i was wrong ah dang it dang it dang it oh i was i was i couldn't aim just throw myself into it so true did you say something i sense you can also go through the portals yeah but then how do i
That was another one.
You think you're doing some damage?
Two plus two is...
Oops.
In base four, I'm fine.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
Come, come, come, come.
Look, look, look at me!
You managed to destroy that part of me.
Unfortunately, as much as I love to know.
Where's it going?
Wait, where'd it go?
to succeed oh wait how the hell do i get up there a big party that all your friends were invited to i invited your best friend the companion cube of course he couldn't come because you murdered him all your other friends couldn't come either because you could hear them there's too much pressure thinking about everything it says so right here in your personal oh i did the wrong color there's too much pressure
Oh, I got it.
Too much pressure.
Can I aim like there?
Oh gosh, okay.
Oh my god.
This is why I don't go through the portals, you guys.
You're gonna want to pack as much living as you can until the next couple of minutes.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, uh, how did I do that?
Alright, alright.
It's the fluid catalyst cracking unit.
It makes you so orphans.
Cool!
Oh my god, I have two minutes left.
I don't think I'll make it.
Which sucks, but that's okay.
Don't choke him.
Over here!
When I said deadly neurotoxin, the deadly was a massive sarcasm quote.
I could take a bath in this stuff, put it on cereal, rub it right up to my arms.
Honestly, it's not deadly at all.
Oh.
Is it gonna hit?
Go!
Oh!
Who's gonna make the cake when I'm gone?
You're wasting your time.
Ah!
Um, so close, I know.
My gosh, lady, please.
Well then, the last thing you want to do...
Okay.
Oh my gosh, we got her.
Ugh.
Oh, this is evil.
That's you.
That's how dumb you sound.
You've been wrong about every single thing you've ever done.
Oh!
One minute!
You're not a scientist.
You're not even a full-time employee.
I got her!
Oh my gosh, one minute, one minute.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run!
I know it's not the only thing standing between us and them.
Unless you have a plan for building some simple computer parts in a big hurry.
Oh!
Good job, won't that, by the way.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh!
We did it!
First try!
It's actually an extremely generous amount of time.
I just don't work well under pressure.
Whoa!
Wee!
Ah!
Oh, who's dragging guys on the wind?
Thank you.
Oh, oh, who's who's dragging me away?
Oh wait, is it song time?
Not yet.
What?
My favorite song.
Oh, God.
Oh, my trauma.
It was always there.
Instead of walking through portals like a normal person.
Of course.
What is that cake made of?
I've always wondered.
that it's song time this was a triumph i'm making a note here huge success it's hard to always change my satisfaction aperture science We do what we must because we can For the blood of all of us Except the ones who are dead But there's no sense crying over every mistake You just keep on trying till you run out of cake And the science gets done and you make a need gone For the people who are still alive It's so cute!
Even after all these years!
I'm not even angry I'm being so sincere right now Even though I broke my heart and killed me I'm 22 pieces And threw every piece into a fire We were so happy for you.
Now there's more in some way to make a beautiful line And we're out of faith and we're resting on our own.
I can't remember the words.
We know all the things we learned For the people who are still alive.
I've heard this song in so long.
Go ahead and leave me.
Oh no.
I think I'd prefer to stay.
inside.
The words are on the screen.
They show up as she says them.
Black Mesa!
That was a joke.
Haha, bad chance.
Delicious and moist.
Look at me still talking when there's science to do.
Ta-da!
Thank you so much for that guys have fun!
I've experimented too long, there is research to be done When the people who are still alive When I leave me I am still alive I'm doing science and I'm still alive I'm here at Lansing and I'm still alive While you're dying, I'll be still alive And when you're dead,
I will be still alive Still alive, still alive.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, yes.
Portal!
Minto,
are you still alive?
No, not even.
I like how it's like, bonus maps, bonus map, challenge maps.
What's advanced chambers like?
Oh.
Oh,
they're like the same, but different.
Interesting.
Oh, my gosh.
Now that I'm thinking about it, I'm like, I remember beating Portal, but I really don't remember beating it.
So, that was so fun.
Now you gotta read the Portal comic.
It's really cute and short.
It ties into Portal 2.
Portal 2 has...
The British guy?
Oh,
Minto Gaming.
Wheatley.
I would like to play Portal 2.
Companion Cube with me.
Wait, I'm the Companion Cube.
I'm censoring it.
I want to send the story.
Thank you so much for the Tony gift.
Thank you.
You guys know that like GIF of...
of Kagame name, Kagame name Len, and he's got the Morakas and he's like shaking them and then he gets progressively like crazier with shaking them.
That's how I feel.
Every time I hear this, every time I hear this song, I feel like that.
I feel like Len.
Does the cake look like coffee beans?
It's, I'm never, hold on, I'm gonna look up what a German coffee cake is, wait, or dot coffee, German, German chocolate cake.
Because I'm like, what is, what is the outside?
It's, it's, looks strange.
Looks like gravel.
I know.
Oh, black forest cake.
Black forest cake.
Oh, so it's like little chocolate shavings.
Oh, oh, and the cherries.
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it.
Oh, black forest cake.
Oh, it looks so yummy.
Oh, I'm hungry for cake.
Me too.
When does Minty cover stay alive?
This was a triumph.
Wait, I don't remember the words all of a sudden.
Wait, I had them.
I was singing along.
They came to me in the moment.
Oh, I'm making a note here.
Huge success.
Jonathan Colton, the writer of Still Alive, has a yearly cruise that sells out every year.
It's full of nerds affectionate.
Wait, what kind of cruise?
Because I've heard of nerd cruises before.
Like, you can go, like, there's, like, like, board game themed cruises and stuff like that.
That sounds fun, though.
Joko Crazy Cruise.
I'm going to look it up.
Oh, I think it, I think.
Oh.
It might be the one that I saw before.
I don't know.
Where do you go?
Wait, 2026?
What's the lineup?
That's next year.
Does he play Still Alive?
Do you think he, like, hates that song?
It's a 72-hour D&D cruise.
Oh, my.
Is there...
Congrats on being a portal, be keep.
Thank you.
Imagine if there were a VTuber cruise.
That sounds insufferable.
I don't recognize any of these people's names, but they're probably cool people, maybe.
If I knew them, I would be like, whoa, my God, I have to go.
Where do you go?
Wait, hold on.
Overview.
Joko Cruz.
Where are we going?
Oh, my gosh, it says, it says, where are we going?
deserve you deserve and delve into unexplored places where do you go oh cabal san lucas loretto and lapaz
to the ocean
pa's virgin i miss my cat i miss my cat this is so fun guys thank you so much for portal i always thought that it was like a much longer game so being able to complete it let me add it to my list of completed games we are killing it we beat a game yesterday we beat a game today portal how many more games do i have left i have just 14
I am going to end it here, though, because tomorrow is an extremely busy day for me.
So, um, if I see what we're on tomorrow's stream, I'll see you.
And if not, thank you so much.
But tomorrow, I have to wake up early, and then I stream.
I have, like, three things sandwiched together.
I wake up early for a thing, I stream, and then I have something at night as well.
So, Portal 2?
I thought I would like to do Portal 2.
I'll try it.
I'll check it out.
I was sad about the cake being a lie until I realized you're the sweetest treat.
I never could ask what I'm not good Recommend Portal 2 for fun plot and quotable lines Three to four streams to beat Okay I got it I blinked at me though already beat Portal Yeah
We need TF2 to complete the orange box collection I know I'm getting to all these games Well I played Portal but like Half-life I'm getting to all these like Valve games I never touched before so it's really fun Yeah yeah yeah So thank you guys
Thank you so much.
That was a fun first stream.
Thank you.
Thanks for sticking around.
Hope you guys had fun.
Wait, hold on.
Let me click back in the game.
Thanks for watching the stream.
I hope you have a good day or night.
I don't know.
I'll see you later next time.
Thanks for watching today's stream I had a lot of fun with you guys I will see you again later I hope you had a fun time and the cake is there And I'm gonna go eat some cake Oh yeah yeah yeah Eat at last time Bye bye